all right paradise
s paradise oh where'd you grow up where
are you from i
am from los angeles california tell me
about
how you grew up you had both your
parents when you were young no
um i grew up in and out of foster care
and um i didn't
establish a relationship with my mother
again to 17
when she was dying of cancer
and you know it was always hard because
i always wanted my mom to be there and
you know love me how she loved all the
rest of her kids but
because of her addiction to
the streets and the prostitution
and drugs she really didn't have time
for me
and so she let me um
get adopted in and so
like i was learning to trust her again
and you know get to know her again you
know
um i've been through quite a lot you
know
like i said at 11 years old i started
prostituting
um as you can say i was a baby
like you know it really didn't
you know dawn on me into
pretty much now like
it's bringing the toll on me it's it's
so stressful like you know
especially if you're doing it for
someone you know uh
for him yeah right how did you get first
introduced to it
i mean um i was tricked forced
you know like he
took me under i was it wasn't i wasn't
willing to go with him you know
i all i knew was i went to a friend's
house
and we were studying and she told me
that her uncle was going to drop us back
off well i'm telling the man hey hey hey
my house is that way he takes me another
way beats me right he drug me
made me learn to love what i was about
to do
you know like you have different men
come date me
and like you know
something had a kid shouldn't have to go
through you know
after a while i i just got used to it
you know like
you know i i guess i can say like i
i feel like that was all i i am able to
be capable of
you know how do you know i'm 25. 25.
this is you've been doing this since you
were 11. how many years old
could you no yeah a lot of people have a
hard time believing that this happens
but there's quite a few girls there this
year it really does
you know i mean they're just not very
vis
they're not some people aren't as lucky
as me you know
i've been shot by you know pimps and
you know i've been brutally beat i have
had to jump out of a car because a man
is trying to kidnap me
you know and it just
doesn't suit me that
i don't encourage anyone to
not be there for their child or not know
where your child whereabouts
is when they're supposed to be coming
home from school you know
because it could be that chance that
they might not come back
and i was one of those cases i mean you
were
yes that's how i started working in the
streets
your mom wasn't really watching you full
time and she didn't pay attention to me
i mean but how if she was having to go
do what i was doing
especially in that neighborhood right
around that area and i'm
talking about figaro and you know and
it it's been a lot of
pain and and and suffering
going through these type of
circumstances
but you know when you get used to a
certain or you get adapted to a certain
situation
that's all i know yeah have you you
think you've got
desensitized to the dangers and all the
stress that this
lifestyle brings no i
i i get reminded of it like every now
and then
you know and do things you get robbed
and raped and things like that still
i mean yeah because i i've been robbed
in right
you know and
you want to bring this money back to
this person so bad
so you don't get hurt
but you never know what can happen
you can see this girl out there she
never come back
i've seen it happen you know
so i don't know what to say like you
know
all i recommend parents please please
just watch your babies because it might
be
just like me that's that baby don't come
home
i have two kids myself i have a daughter
and it's sad but my baby know the game
and she she knows mommy's going to work
at night
she was telling me at four years old
like mommy
mommy you're going out mom you're going
out be
i hope i see you and come back you know
it
hurts not so much yeah kids learn by
example
it would be fun you know i just
recommend
it it don't matter if it's a boy a girl
just watch your baby you know like
i wouldn't dare want to see my 10 year
old daughter out there
so listening and and selling her body
like it's not fun it's not something
that
i'll say oh i wake up today home with a
lovely day i'm gonna go
date a man on fake a stranger
don't know they're probably not straight
crazy man could be a psychotic
psychopath you know it's just like
it's kind of funny to watch these
beautiful young women with these
how do i say it less than attractive
males i mean like like like if i do i'm
the kind of guy that can't really get a
female if i get
one more fat guy that don't have a venus
i'm gonna
it's it's kind of hilarious to watch it
maybe if you get past the
the the horror of it all right you'll
see that you'll see some of the most
beautiful women ever
right beautiful like like spectacularly
beautiful women
with the the least attractive males you
could ever imagine
right right and they're the girls are
running after the guys
the girls are running after the guys
right i've seen this and it's like
whoa it's like they're they're they're
trying to get the guys to like
pick them up and the guys are saying no
sometimes because they wanna they want
to go with whatever
right oh my god i'm like
i i got out of jail i said oh wow
this [ __ ] is different
what is what is doing this kind of work
taught you about men
and some of them are selfish
some of them are self-centered they
all just think about themselves
and
just know that it can go from
i love you babe to smack smack [ __ ]
where's my money
fast they're manipulative too
are they drunk or high or whatever
usually they can be
yeah are you drunk or high usually um
sometimes
but when i go working out
[Music]
i don't get high i don't i don't drink i
don't do
none of that because first of all
not only do i need to be so we're safe
and sober i need to be aware of my
surroundings because i never know who's
out to get me not as far as
i want some [ __ ] tie [ __ ] no awesome
i want this [ __ ] this [ __ ] it makes
money i need her money
yeah so pimp hmm yeah i feel
cause trust and believe they don't just
go for one girl
it's a lot of them it's a stable
it's the game hello
what emotions do you go through
up and down depression
angry sometimes i sometimes i sit there
just quiet
and i don't say anything because i never
know how someone might respond or what
they're going to do because
do you see any way out do you see any
options for you yeah i
do i want to start my own business
i want to do hair and i also want to
open two
like two business i want one that's
going to do hair
nails and massages and stuff then my
second one is going to be
towards uh organization
to help girls with soliciting and even
and even male
guys and prostitutes because there
is male 1 you know you can't just think
about what we go through they can do
things too
yeah so i know i'm going to make it out
of this i know i'm not going to be
like i was just telling my friend i'm
like hey i know i'm not going to be a 30
year old
i know i'm going to have my business and
i know i can say
hey yeah i grew up from this but
you can make something out of yourself i
want somebody kid
man if i can only save one i'll feel
good yeah
that'd be great are you kids with you
are you raising them
um yes they're with me but as of right
now i'm like no
because i don't drag my kids along in
the street with me
i have a 10 year old daughter and i have
a five-year-old son
i'm being a mom i've always been a mom
just spending the time is what i need to
get better at
so if i can get off these streets and
get my business started and
really i'm my own boss so
i'll be able to retain and keep up with
their schedule too
is it scary for a girl that does this
kind of work and probably gets
semi-addicted to the
fast money to just to imagine a life
that's like
square damn this time i gotta wait for
two weeks
to get a paycheck it's it's a scary i
know what to go do
it's a frightening adjustment right oh
my god it's so scary
i mean i've done it once i try
no but to trade instant fast money
for come on a job where they're taking
out taxes and they're paying you
two weeks later i mean first of all i
shouldn't have to be paying taxes
anyways because this country is not
doing [ __ ] for me
but yeah tell me about the tricks oh my
god
some of them they're they're cool
they're genuine they keep
their promise that they you know said
that it they will make or whatever you
know
and then there's some it's like you have
to have protection on you you have to
have a knife
some scissors or something sharp do you
what do you carry
me i can't read pepper spray or a taste
and it's because i have been raped by a
trick um i have had to jump out
a car not knowing if i'm about to break
a bone and we're on a freeway
it can be easy and it can be dangerous
like i said it could be a slight chance
you might not make it home
don't let it be you nobody else
please and then having kids makes that
yes making kids happy just like oh my
god i look at it so
[ __ ] different now i'm like hell no
like i gotta get a
consistent job like i need to make sure
i got my apartment i don't stay with
nobody else
like or they're putting me out after
they get my money or they know i'm gonna
go get some money so they're just
waiting on me to pay a bill or you know
you think you're addicted to the fast
money and all that
yes i know i am yeah
i know you're heard not to me come on
now you know
once you get over the initial fear of
doing it
then it's just a matter of yeah i mean
once you get started it's like well now
it becomes a drug
you get addicted facts you've been in
love before have you been in love before
yeah i've been in love with it fam
but yes i've had a boyfriend if that's
what you're asking mark
yes baby i've had a boyfriend i got a
boyfriend now
yeah he doesn't ask for my money
you say you really don't even have to do
it but hey
honey it's on you hi you're grown up and
he's okay with you
doing this kind of work not really i
mean we
broke up we're broken up now but yeah
he said i choose my lifestyle morning
so yeah you have friends
no can't trust him
what is this kind of work taught you
about human nature
do you feel like everyone's out after
themselves yes
i i honestly do because someone can say
they're honestly trying to help me and
then like
turn their back on me and like oh you
didn't give me no money that's why i
didn't help
yeah but you have to remember that this
lifestyle that you're
immersed in is all everyone's a hustler
right
you know the tricks the the the pimps
the
other girls even the cops are or even
sometimes
[ __ ] i've had a cop off for me
either you date me or you you go to jail
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's thinking about doing this
listen to your mom like if she tells you
don't go out late at night because it
could be dangerous baby you can end up
in a situation like me
and your innocence kid completely took
him from you and
now you don't care about who sees you
out there
who you know who cares and
you it don't matter when you're getting
your money
and when you get in the game like
prostitution
baby you're grown and no matter how old
you are
be careful be careful because it's not
safe
and just make sure you always let
someone know where you're at
and i'm not talking about no pimp none
of that i'm talking about
let your family know because it could be
a slight chance maybe you might be that
person that can't go home
that don't make him so my words for a
girl young girls are
just be careful baby be careful
be careful because
i would be sad to see somebody on a new
somebody baby somebody child
i've seen it i've seen it
and i don't know what happened to that
girl
and i just don't know like i pray she
had just went to jail
or something better i i don't think that
wouldn't think that somebody like would
be like a serial killer or
craig let's kill her and you know kill a
girl
you know for just coming to do what she
was supposed to
do you see the limits of what you'll do
for money changing
like you start doing riskier things no
i'm taking the risk i'm already taking
one the big one
said i got 172 cases of prostitution in
each state
what states have you worked in i'm
working in arizona
texas new jersey
south carolina north carolina washington
i've been all over
the cross country the temps take you out
yeah but you gonna make some money
you gonna have a ball too i also went to
the players ball
is it hard for you to give away all your
money
hell yeah yes it is
and i i mean and i got to deal with
other [ __ ] attitudes
and i got to give you my money where's
your cut no [ __ ] where's my cat
because i have to deal with all this
insane [ __ ] and the reason you don't get
out is
what i am am i ready
i'm just gonna take it one day at a time
i'm young the reason you don't get away
from the pimp
is why you can't
no
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
in the streets don't let nobody
she's from nobody
and when you out there you got to be a
big girl
because you're doing big things
don't let me get all teary-eyed
it's okay all right paradise thank you
so much for talking with me thank you
thank you very much